let's think back to what you did last
lesson you learn two big ones to do with
angles do you remember what they were
today the first one club always gave you
to dinner by the way
complimentary how do you spell it how do
you spell it
what's the next letter said correctly
the complimentary it was one of the ways
you learn yes
last time assessing and is spelt with an
e what happens when you spell it with an
i what does it mean when there's an I in
the middle yes yes that's right so this
is saying something nice about someone
right Varick whereas when you put an e
in bed if you put a ry because of the
agitator they fit together has it work
so mathematicians have kind of borrowed
that word and they've used it to mean
two angles that add up to 90 degrees or
or a writing okay what was the other
word to remember what it was yep
well done supplementary
so as you remember supplementary it
sounds like complimentary we good reason
what does it mean when Shane was are
supplementary yes
Arizona Trinity okay so give me some
examples because somebody will name some
pairs of angles that are to hydrate
anyone yeah 1990 okay good another care
yeah 20 and 160 also equal to 180 good
these are both good I like the bit
boring but lots of 10 come on we can be
a little more adventurous than that so I
want to give me one that's you know do
anymore I'm just stretching that's cool
yeah okay let's do one more
I did astronauts really great that's
fine so these pair mangos supplementary
supplementary supplementary separately
we can also say that hundred
seventy-nine is the complement of what
and what is that starting supplement and
one is the supplement of 179 you've
little this thing is useful yes not at
me please
yes okay right let's move on a little
bit so that was revision pick a color
the news so petty you can make
angles at a point now we all know what a
point is don't we
what is a point here's a point okay
now we can draw a series of angles at
this point for instance I could draw
there are for a moose at a point okay
why don't we name them let's call this
one over here a degrees be the reason
I'm actually not naming the deadline I
met you saying this size but this C
degrees and now the question is well at
least one of many is that what do all of
these angles a plus B plus C plus D what
do they add up to someone hasn't said
something 360 degrees let's write that
down
a plus B okay that's equal to
now one of the quick ways that you could
see that is to look at this diagram
right and take any of these what are
these cool by the way do you remember
the lines that make up the two sides of
an egg and these stops with it does stop
with a butts let's morons yeah their
arms right because for instance if we
just have a look at D everything it's
like two arms and D's in between now if
I get rid of most of these arms I mean
you're rid of this one and this one in
this one okay and then truly angle that
results you'll get this okay if I've
gotten rid of all the rest of the arms
so it goes all the way around and then
come back this is really serious
it's such an important angle that we
give it a special name do you remember
what it's called
yes it's called a revolution
sir our first thing to say is that
angles at a point add up to 360 degrees
all angles at a point make a revolution
okay so let's write that down it's
important I do put it in a different
color put these books right add up to
360 degrees okay
. so let's do a simple one first let's
see how we might use this in an exam
okay drill for yourself by the way for
all of these with your arms and that
kind of thing you really not need to use
a ruler it's not quite an angle when
you've got like a curvy being in another
carry thing it's like where's the angle
it's somewhere in there I don't know so
use a ruler you have one you go and grab
one bar from a friend have a nice
straight line for all of your arms
that's a bit better okay
now if I gave you a few different angles
here for instance let's go with that 179
gonna go from Chelsea before okay and
I'll put one more angle in here what
does that mean climb maybe that's this
angle here that we don't know okay let's
give it a size let's call it X okay so
how would I write out the working to
show this answer and not just get the
answer
remember I've been saying this whole
time the work and you put down the way
that you get your solution is just as
important as a solution itself
so any suggestions let's let's go back
to panel show me for what I automated my
very very first line okay I'm gonna go
ahead and 79 there is get a besom
subtraction that happens so name is on
the right track but where can we go from
here
okay hold on hold on
hands down hands down there there now I
think we're going well so far okay
but all the answers I'm hearing I
actually think we'll get you to the
right
final answer okay but I don't think
they're the best word right let me try
to explain what this thing up here which
you wrote in special writing and put a
big box around me hey what I write down
here in numbers or to reflect what I've
written up here in words and I say that
again it's so funny what I write down
here in numbers or to reflect what I've
written up here in words you're gonna
get this a lot you'll you'll learn
different properties inequalities about
maths and geometry and when you have
them in words you should translate them
into numbers now have a look and goes at
a point add up to look at that right it
was a point add up so if I want my
numbers here to flip my words here I
should have a whole bunch of additions
shouldn't I
179 plus 80 that's a good start but
that's only two of the three angles at
my point
what's the thinning it's okay so this is
what I'd like you to average now now
this is these are the angles at a point
okay
now when I add them all up they should
add to 360 so I will say this
now by the way the chicory now since
we're just learning this idea right it's
really important to actually write down
after this statement you justify it
after this statement you explain why
it's true
that's our justification it means so
therefore after you've written this why
I actually like you to write this again
put it in parentheses over here I kind
of run out of space on my board so I'm
just gonna put that in but you should
say this is how you're working should
set out 179 degrees for say degrees plus
X degrees equals 360 degrees because
angles at a point
add up to 360 degrees okay all right now
we can do some subtraction we want X
don't win so in order to get X by itself
okay
I need to get these two guys over the
other side so therefore I'm going to SAP
subtract 179 and 80 from both sides okay
like so 360 minus minus is that okay
people all right with that you see what
I've done I've kept it balanced the
crazy was still balanced what I did to
the left-hand side subtract these two
I've done to the right-hand side as well
great now of course you could reach your
calculator but I think we can do Bend to
that especially because the number that
were chosen for instance I tell look at
these two these two if I made that 180
360 minus 180 what would you get 360
minus 180 think about it I just get 180
again wouldn't I he's 180 is - 3 6
so if I don't subtract quite that much
should be what anyone should miss it
said okay and that's pretty easy